[موسيقى]
كيف كان يقضي يومياته الاولى بعد سقوط
بغداد في التاسع من ابريل فتره التخفي
يعني بعد ان اجتمع مع
بعض القيادات يوم 11 وقال لهم يعني الان
القتال بالسلاح الخفيف
استعدوا للقتال بسلاح الخفيف
ويوم 11 اخبرني انه طلب من حمايتهم
مرافقيه الذهاب يعني كل سبيل حاله وابقى
عناصر بسيطه جدا واتجه الى مدينه رمادي
وتحديدا الى عند عائله الخربيط عائله
عربيه
[موسيقى]
كيف فسر لك صدام حسين سقوط النظام بهذه
السرعه دخول يعني احتمال الاحتلال بسرعه
عدم تكافؤ القوه يعني القوات العراقيه
كانت تقاتل بدون غطاء جوي
لسمتي ولا حربي
الفرق شاسع جدا بين سلاح الامريكي والسلاح
العراقي المتهالك العراق محاصر ايضا منذ
1990 يعني 13 سنه محاصر فامر طبيعي ودقات
القوه عظمى معها اربعين دوله يعني اكيد
الموضوع مختلف تماما هذه الاسباب التي
قالها لك والسبب الاخر استخدام امريكا
للسلاح النووي التكتيكي
في بغداد ولد صدمه يعني الجندي العراقي
يشوف الدبابه تنصهر امامه وتتحول الى سائل
وهول الضربه يعني ولد يعني الى يعني
تداعيات
[موسيقى]
هو ما يطبق في كل محاكم العراق كل جنايات
العراق
بنظام الجلسه وبكيفك من اقرر تجي